this is Dominic Dominic works at a
5-star restaurant called the pixel
palace they're some of videogames most
popular celebrities pop in to have a
drink sometimes they share stories and
even secrets because as we all know what
the bartender here's is confidential
isn't it
so I'm sitting there tending bar when in
walks one of my favorite customers
sellers now samus very rarely takes off
her battle gear even when she's in a bar
most of her drinks have to be sipped
through straws but this time she took
off her helmet why because she was
smiling she was so happy about something
so I told us at Summit she look very
perky today she says what do you mean by
that and I said no no the smile the
personality he seemed very perky and she
goes hello hi omelets it's because I'm
in a very very good mood she says and so
I asked her why you're so happy then she
says I've found someone I'd been looking
for for a very long time
I'll said who's that she said Justin
Bailey I said who's Justin Bailey she
said for the longest time nobody knew
but apparently there was this code where
if you insert his name into the game you
get to see her run around the whole
entire game in a bathing suit and she
did not like that at all she founded the
meaning she found it embarrassing
because she never took that suit off
ever even was you went to judge you it
still went she was very protective of
her body I didn't want anyone else to
see it so I said well okay so you found
this just a bailey guy who Lizzie and
she said for the longest time nobody
knew people folios a guy who wants some
sort of prophetic contest an out-of-work
hacker Ellis even a rumor that he was an
alien chihuahua from outer space only
fella bastard a mob and she told me he
wasn't any of those things told me that
he was just a chubby game programmer bad
acne thick glasses 40 years old and
still living with his parents so I asked
how did you meet him and she said
actually I'm not have been lying at the
DMV
said the DMV and she said yeah I have to
drive to she doesn't even take the suit
on for the picture of a license
apparently but I digress
so she bumps into him in line and she
hears him say the name and she taps him
on the back and says you made that did
you say lately I said yeah yeah I did
so this is getting really exciting and I
ask ourself what you do then so you
confront him is the score you've been
looking for for years and years so what
you do just as I showed him at the
crotch and I'll said what she said I
shot him in the crotch I said you mean
like they didn't she said no gun bang
boom for name and testicles all over the
place and I said are you serious and she
yeah course I'm serious
I'll say well what did the Constitution
say be there must have been cops there
she says oh they tried to stop me but I
shot them both in the face cops are not
very threatening we have a giant suit of
armor you see and understand them
they're just dumbfounded by their son I
can't believe what I'm hearing
so I'll start so well what you do next
she said I just took him home and
tortured him you know can't the generic
strap him down cut up in his belly and
take out his insides but I'll said you
you tortured a man to death
Jesus no no no they're about to death
just a breaking point between life and
death
so I'll start it do you do the safety
and she says oh just once in a while
when somebody doesn't treat me right I
said like who this is Oh
girl Scout's Jehovah's Witnesses pizza
delivery boys mailmen quite frankly I'm
at a loss for words and she says how
come every time that you kill an alien
from another world you're considered a
hero yet every time you slaughter five
to ten innocent bystanders you're
considered a psycho well on legitimately
terrified right now I mean I'm crapping
my pants beyond belief then all I could
think to ask her was what did she do it
just as cuz they were looking at my body
bunch of bastard she said all they ever
think about when they look at me as my
body and I'll said even in the battle
gear she said especially in the battle
gear and she told me that she just want
to set them straight that the body is in
fact a vessel very fragile painful
vessel that you just want to jam that
into their heads before she crammed her
laser blast into their heads that is and
all said that's a very interesting story
you got there Somerset there up anyway
you thought about making people not look
at your body outside of torturing them
she says well I did have this one idea
you see I just bought this brand-new
zero suit
she said that's gonna change everything
no more people can look at my body
they're gonna respect me as a woman
known as an object
have you seen her zero suit the thing is
tighter than saran wrap so she pays for
her train and starts to head out the
door before she leaves I'll say ollie
samus um take it easy
she says delay after I get this news
zero suit everybody is going to respect
me
two weeks later she shot the balls of
the Leisure Suit Larry I guess he didn't
wipe respect her but then again I don't
think he respects many women I just
don't know that people haven't come and
I mean okay Leisure Suit Larry has a
common bond everyone else just seems
owned just a tad extreme but I guess
that's the idea in a video game welt
everything's an extreme sex and violence
is heal all strange things as a
bartender see it all strange things at
the pixel Palace so I'll see a lot of
strange things as a bartender at the
pixel palace that ain't no man
you